dernière ligne droite pour les remparts
de tours plus que quatre matches avant
la fin de la saison régulière quatre
matches charente connaître leurs stores
enjeu une qualification pour les
play-offs
oursel va falloir accroché la huitième
place une mission compliquée mais pas
impossible
les avis restent encore deux points dans
ce championnat en quatre matches et
restent dos - c'est beaucoup de points
factuellement faux aller étape par étape
on était avec match par match et
aujourd'hui on se bat encore pour
annuler ces impositions premier obstacle
de taille cholet qui se présente samedi
sur la patinoire tourangelle cholet 2e
au classement seulement 4 défaites au
compteur en 22 matches joués est un jeu
semble compliqué pour les joueurs de
bobine est il un exploit est
pratiquement obligatoire pour continuer
d'y croire
devoir à souk ahras et surtout les les
aspects jobs est très disciplinée avec
cette équipe là c'est une équipe
complète de détail très important demain
de ce résultat dépendra le reste de la
saison une défaite conjuguée à une
victoire dans même temps de caen
principal concurrent pour la huitième
place anéantirait pratiquement toute
chance de qualification
un match à enjeu quand même les jouets
l'entraîneur québécois la boîte tabac la
fesci aux partisans ils auront une
ambiance incroyable c'est demain et je
crois que cinquième joueur très
important de mettre dans ce match-là et
nos gars sont tous prêts à ces la moitié
belle équipe certes un beau spectacle
une chose est sûre l'opération maintien
objectif de début de saison est quant à
elle en très bonne voie comme il est
devrait donc en toute logique prolongé
son contrat avec les remparts une
prolongation de deux ans est
actuellement en négociations avec le
président